i love pendulum
i almost put pendulum i went to watch
pendulum live and it was probably like
the greatest
experience ever i nearly died like four
times being stepped on to death but that
must have been like audio crack man dude
it was insane so i went to get on watch
pendulum it was in like a warehouse like
this concrete warehouse yeah yeah yeah
and it was just like some kind of like
satanic ritual it looked like because
there was just this thing was so tall
yeah yeah so you just see this massive
like hunk of concrete and then just
depends i'm just going hard on this yeah
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] whenever when
tarantula came on that was insane
everyone went insane it was just like
i've never been in such a like
just intense atmosphere it was so funny
i don't normally like going to concerts
but that one was really fun because i
need the lyrics as well
everyone remembers the opening to
witchcraft yeah yeah that's the one song
everyone would just start seeing it's
like chiller
i've been i've been listening to the
pendulum since i was like [ __ ] 12 and
i would listen to them they were pretty
inescapable back when yeah yeah yeah
blood sugar yeah yeah i remember the
probably nightmares as well
blood sugar was prodigies am i talking
about yeah yeah it was like pendulum and
prodigy where they were just like
[ __ ] massive yeah i was like they
were inescapable at a point where like i
remember like they came out as like the
in the age where i just started going
clubbing and like you'd hear a pendulum
song and a prodigy song at least once in
every [ __ ] show
pendulum was definitely like my early
inspiration before i found like i
started really getting into like daft
punk right yeah obviously interstellar
uh is amazing and all the music videos
just go so goddamn well with the songs
and
not the movie
not the soundtrack to the movie it's
amazing and then you got uh andy
yeah so this is just like city pop this
is the i can't stop loneliness song have
you heard that one yeah i [ __ ] love
that song i can't stop
the loneliness i don't know what i love
we're gonna get coffee right now because
it's really good that's why i'm sitting
in bed i'm singing it on purpose very
good but i love i love shitty pop um
obviously i don't know how to
encapsulate all of city pop i could just
put plastic love and quality paper you
know i feel like city pop has definitely
blown up in the past what four or five
years it's going crazy even the weekend
on his new album samples a lot of city
park oh yeah and it's so goddamn good
it's like city pop with like the vocals
for god um it's just amazing it's so
good and yeah i mean i absolutely adore
city pop it makes me nostalgic for that
time that i lived in japan in the 80s
and yeah stared out the window yeah
definitely and was in the bubble period
was it literally plastic love that
literally like kind of reinvigorated
this city pop friends that's like
happening so because yeah yeah
occasionally but i don't think anyone
the movement hadn't really taken off i
think plastic love is what really got
people into thinking about listening to
other songs because i definitely heard
silly uh city pop songs before this
right but never enough to make me be
like is this a genre yeah i don't know
what this is it was also just like such
a mystery as to why it was that song
that blew up like this i've seen like
documentaries on youtube about like why
did plastic love blow up and [ __ ] and
it's like because and i'm just like
because it's a good song
yeah i mean like nothing more also like
the youtube algorithm just works in
[ __ ] mysterious ways exactly i mean
there's two ways i get recommended songs
it's memes
or youtube algorithm yeah honestly memes
is like a really underrated way to
discover new music because a lot like
memes is so good a lot of meme songs are
actually like good songs yeah you don't
you forget that they're good songs
because you've just heard it bass
boosted so many times maybe i'm yours is
ironically like a [ __ ] amazing song
and it's so [ __ ] stupid that i can't
listen to this song without thinking of
ladies and gentlemen we got it
and then follow me
it's awful ruin my life no because i
remember when i heard first heard that
song it got recommended to me on youtube
and i was just like oh it's the meme
song and i was waiting for like the bass
boost to come in and then it just like
it was just the song and i remember
thinking damn why did they base boost
this [ __ ] masterpiece man it's like
taking the mona lisa and like [ __ ]
spitting on it you know ironically like
crap dance song yeah it's a good song
and uh the shooting star song remember
that one oh that was a good song
oh
yeah you know that one yeah that one was
like good actually
they're great songs all right well
that's my three by three uh go and check
some of them out you might like it if
you like daft punk you'll probably like
a lot of these i want to listen to
parcels yeah you should try it yeah i
love parcels man some of those songs are
so [ __ ] good all right well that's my
uh initial trash taste in music thank
god that's out there
before before we move on obviously uh
obviously you talked about a lot of your
music that you're into now well like
what i i'm curious what you listen to as
a kid like do you remember or did you
just not put any of them on
like as early as you can remember yeah
fighters uh
uh that was a big one before clyro
uh pendulum prodigy
then i had that weird phase where i was
like yeah calvin harris is really good i
i was actually like this close man
calvin harrison well he did that he did
racism
but like i would be lying if i'd like
didn't go through a phase where i
listened to a [ __ ] ton of calvin house
i'm not immune to [ __ ] taste right there
was a point where i listened to a lot a
lot of calvin harris did you listen to a
lot of david guetta as well oh god yeah
i did you know you know when you listen
to that uh swedish housemate airplanes
in the night sky song yeah you're like
how about i just want all music that
sounds exactly like this yeah black ips
you know
when i had like no no [ __ ]
personality of my own i would just
listen to what the charts told me the
billboards like the billboards top 20. i
want to i want to fit in i want to seem
normal i'm going to say i like this song
i love that new calvin harris song you
know
i i felt like i almost like listened to
that music just so i could have i could
keep up with what people were talking
about
because i didn't want to get bullied for
liking like [ __ ] scottish
bands one talked about with that well
you know
like there was a lot of social pressure
yeah like me listening to calvin harris
was the equivalent of me watching
football matches so like i could have
something to talk about he's like oh
yeah you see uh that's true yeah yeah
you see the letter match oh yeah the new
calvin how the song came out that was
pretty good wasn't it but like i feel
like i never really had a defined music
taste because i was kind of you know as
well back then i had to
uh find a means to get a hold of it yeah
and that often was a big limiting factor
and what i could discover i did the
opposite i was like oh i listened to
that recent calvin harris song [ __ ]
[ __ ] in it
i've never seen it well you have good
taste
music
you have good taste as well and i didn't
even think that i was like i didn't even
listen to it i'm just giving you a hard
time